SPEAKER 1: So thank you guys for
joining us for our first Google
Talks in the Birmingham office.
I have the great pleasure today
to introduce Bridget Russo,
the CMO of Shinola.
Before I do, for
those of you who
don't have a deep background
on the company itself,
I wanted to give
you a little bit.
It was conceived in 2011.
So when we think
about our own brand,
Shinola is only
about five years old.
It is the maker of modern
handcraft watches, bicycles,
leather goods, journals,
and pet accessories,
of which it sounds
like they're expanding
into even more products.
So we'll hear from
Bridget about that.
They're really
focused on again, you
think about those
of you who work
in the automotive industry,
some of the importance
of handcrafting, leather,
some of the more upscale ways
that we try and convey
important elements of our auto
manufacturers background.
A lot of that is in the
messages that Shinola
brings into the market.
So really interesting there.
As far as their locations,
those of you probably know,
they're headquartered here
in Detroit in the College
for Creative Studies
building, which
was a former automotive
research lab.
And then since the
company's founding,
they have I think
about seven stores now
that they've opened up.
As Bridget herself, a little
bit of background on Bridget.
Her background started in
PR, which is coming in handy.
Obviously as a CMO, you have
to deal with a lot of things,
particularly in
social media nowadays.
With her background in PR, she
started on the agency side--
very familiar to some of
you-- and then moved over
onto the client side, working
with Diesel in the fashion
industry.
From there she moved
and started to work
with Eden, which is a company
that Bono started with his wife
to support some of the-- to
drive industry in Africa.
And that moved her into
her own consultancy,
which a lot of
our Googlers do is
to start their own businesses.
And from there it led her
to Shinola and from New York
to Detroit.
And so with that, we welcome
her and want to hear her story
and learn a bit
more about Shinola.
So with that, I'll
welcome Bridget.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIDGET RUSSO: Thank you for
taking the time out of your day
to hear the Shinola story.
Can everybody hear me OK?
OK.
Cool.
So I'm going to take
you through quickly,
since we do have the
fireside chat, and I do
want to give you
guys the opportunity
to ask questions afterwards.
So I'll kind of whiz
through this a little bit,
give you a little background as
to why we started the company,
and what's up next in
terms of new categories.
So we started with building
a watch factory in Detroit.
Back in 2011, people thought
our founder, Tom Kartsotis,
was crazy.
Why not accept
that manufacturing
is gone from this country?
Why not let the rust and weeds
finish what they started?
Why not just embrace the
era of disposability?
And why didn't we buy a warmer
coat before we moved here?
Through three Detroit
winters, we've
asked ourselves these
questions, and worked
not to find our answers,
but to build it.
So really from the
beginning, the intention
was always to not
only be in a city
where manufacturing was in its
history and in its lifeblood,
but also to be in
a city where we
could have a positive
impact on the community.
In our case, in creating jobs.
Here's a little video.
So this is where it all began.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The question isn't why
do you build a watch
factory in Detroit, it's why
you built one anywhere else?
This is the city that
made this country.
With its steel, with its
skill, with its labor.
Re-establishing
trades that haven't
been seen in this country
in a generation or more.
It's a tall order
to return to form.
But it's what hundreds
of Shinola employees
work towards every
day here in Detroit,
where we believe in
the beauty of industry,
the glory of manufacturing.
Shinola.
Where American is made.
[END PLAYBACK]
BRIDGET RUSSO: So it
started with watches.
We launched our first
product in 2013.
The factory opened
in 2012, which
is when I started
with the company.
Alongside watches, we also
had bicycles, leather goods,
and journals.
But really our messaging
from the beginning
was watches built in
Detroit of quality.
And so we started there.
Our first watch was the Runwell.
If you guys were
around at that time
paying attention to
some of the marketing,
we had launched the Runwell
watch before we actually
have product in the market.
So that was March 2013.
The previous year we
had a brand website up
where we were speaking
directly to the consumer
through social-- primarily at
the time Twitter and Facebook--
and really telling people
about our story directly,
not going through the trades
and sort of the normal way
you would launch a brand.
Showing product before
it was finished,
selling swatches of leather,
talking about our relationship
with the College for Creative
Studies, where we're based,
to the degree that some
people were confused as
to what we were.
They would be like, are
you a watch company?
Are you a bike company?
Are you a school?
But that really helped lead us
to the launch of the Runwell.
Fast forward to March of 2013.
We had about 10,000 people on
our e-mail lists at that point.
And about the same
number of followers
on Facebook and Twitter.
And we launched the watch.
We hadn't actually
made the watch yet.
$550 price point.
We had 2,500 units.
By the end of that
week, so eight days,
we sold out of the watch,
which was pretty incredible.
We really didn't know
in the beginning.
There was some who thought
that Shinola would actually
be more of a company to make
watches for other brands.
But then when we saw the
strength of the Runwell
in the Shinola brand, we
decided to go full force.
Subsequently, we've
launched these other
what we call platforms.
And most recently the Canfield,
which is a refined Runwell.
Bicycles.
So bicycles, going back
to the '80s really,
that production went offshore.
The US primarily one
of the biggest names,
Schwinn, you might know.
The brand's still out there.
But it's not owned by
the family anymore.
They were one of the last
to move their manufacturing
overseas.
So they lost the right-- or
sold the rights to their name.
But they did hold onto one
piece of their business,
called Waterford
Precision Cycles.
So they were making
custom bicycles, $10,000
and up, that people
would wait months for.
So we met Sky Yaeger.
How we approach all
of our categories
is really finding leaders
within that category.
So in the case of
bikes, that was Sky.
Sky said, I know the
guy we need to go to.
Richard Schwinn up
there in the corner
is a great grandson of the man
who started Schwinn bicycles.
And we approached him
and said, what would it
take for you to make
bicycles for Shinola?
And we said we'll probably
make about 1,000 a year.
He's like, I need
to hire more people.
So we're like great.
Right in line with
our messaging.
So some people ask, well,
why are the bikes so pricey?
The Runwell is $3,000.
The Bixby that you
see there is $2,000.
And it's because of the
quality and the craftsmanship
that goes into it.
So we make the frame
and fork with Waterford.
And then we assemble the
bikes, as you see there,
in our Detroit store.
Paper.
We work with a bindery in Ann
Arbor, or close to Ann Arbor,
called Malloy Brothers.
Sorry, I had a brain
fart there for a minute.
And again, we really
saw the market.
So with all of our
categories, we really
look at them in two
ways-- as brand builders
or as volume drivers.
So bicycles, leather,
and soon to be
audio, which I'll tell
you about in a little bit,
are really the volume drivers.
And things like the journals,
bicycles, pet accessories,
are the brand builders.
They're equally as important.
But it really helps us
not only kind of continue
to provide products that are
relevant to the lifestyle
of our consumer, but also
to add a point of difference
in the marketplace.
So if you go into a
Neiman's or a Nordstrom
in the watch department you
might see a Shinola bike
hanging.
We actually made all of the
buyers of the big department
stores come to Detroit before
they wanted to buy the line.
So that definitely
was helpful in helping
them show the full breadth
of the brand in their stores.
Leather.
We recently signed on
a few years ago now.
John and Richard.
They had a brand called
Lambertson and Truex
that did very well.
They're highly regarded
in the fashion industry.
Then they moved on to Tiffany's
where they built their leather
business to a $50
million business,
and were kind of
in semi-retirement
when we approached them to
run our leather business.
So we started with a
small leather goods,
and have expanded now
into bags, wallets, belts.
Come this fall, we'll really
have a full representation
for women.
So again, looking at leaders
within the categories
to lead the design
and production.
And then pet accessories.
So these are these
fun categories.
Just as much work, but
ones that really help
create the buzz
around the brand.
Because it's not
every day that you
launch a new watch
or a new bicycle
or a new range of journals.
But this is an opportunity to
get that PR earned media value.
And then the marketing.
So it all started--
this was the ad that we
ran going back in March 2013.
At first we weren't
going to advertise.
We're like, no.
We're not that kind of brand.
We're not going to do it.
Right about when
I came on board,
we hired an agency called
Partners and Spade, based out
of New York.
They really helped us design the
next version of the site, which
is pretty much
what you see today,
and really put a
stake in the ground
around Detroit-built
watches of quality.
And we decided to
take this ad out.
We ran it in the "New York
Times," "USA Today," "Detroit
Free Press," in the "Wall
Street Journal" sort of mid week
in the process of
selling the watch
and by the time the "New York
Times," Sunday Times style,
ran on Sunday.
They were sold out already.
You might remember this.
When Detroit
announced bankruptcy,
a few days later, we ran
this in the "New York Times."
"To those who have
written off Detroit,
we give you the Birdie."
The Birdie happened to
be a watch that we were
releasing at the same time.
And again, the PR value
on this was amazing.
And again, you know
for me, if you guys
are familiar with PR
Newswire, that's where you
would put your press releases.
I really saw the "New York
Times" as our PR Newswire.
I found that when you had
something relevant that
had culturally relevant
impact, the "New York Times"
was a great vehicle.
When it came to Mothers
Day and Fathers Day,
and we were just announcing the
Runwell in a different color,
that was probably
not the best ROI
to run a full page ad
in the "New York Times."
And then the second year
we worked with Bruce Weber.
So Bruce Weber, you
guys might know,
the famed fashion photographer.
I like to say the first
year we showed people
what was behind our doors,
highlighting the people that
work in the factory and
establishing ourselves
as a leader within the industry.
And then the next year with
our work with Bruce, really
is a love letter to Detroit,
celebrating the people
outside of our doors,
and why we came
to Detroit in the first place.
Last year you might
remember the launch
in April of the Apple Watch.
We called the agency I think
a week before and said, hey,
can you guys come
up with something
that would kind of just
get us in the conversation
of this major launch?
And so they came up with this.
"A watch so smart
that it can tell you
the time just by looking at it.
Runwell.
Just smart enough."
So we ran these ads,
again, sprinkle here
and there. "Wall Street
Journal," "New York Times,"
ran some digital around it too.
And again, the buzz that
we created off of it
was really tremendous.
In a time when-- and
we all know how much
Apple spends on advertising.
So had a few friends
that work there.
And I got a text from
one saying, cheeky.
Which it was.
And then this year.
In an election
year, we knew jobs
was going to be a hot topic.
And we really wanted
to celebrate the fact
that we created over 500
jobs since we launched.
And so we came out
with this campaign.
"There's a funny thing
that happens when you build
factories in this country.
It's called jobs."
And again, really highlighting
the people behind the products.
We are a true
manufacturing company
built not by the things we
make, but by the people who
make them.
This year in the past, we were
primarily-- our media plan
was primarily print.
And we started to see
some diminishing returns
I would say, mid-last year.
So we really did a shift
towards digital this year,
working with premium partners
like "Vanity Fair," "Elle,"
"Harper's Bazaar,"
"Vice," to create content.
So some of that you
guys might have seen.
We'll continue with that
for second half of the year
around big product launches.
So continuing to talk
about our leather,
our watches, and expand
our reach outside
of our media consumers.
Our big push for second half of
the year will be around women.
The challenge that we do have
is that talking about jobs
is great.
But when you're trying to sell
a hobo bag, talking about jobs
doesn't really help.
It doesn't mean that women
don't care about creating jobs.
But when you're trying to sell
someone this great leather bag,
that messaging doesn't
always link up together.
So that's something that
we're working through
now to understand
probably around September,
around the debates, the jobs
messaging will come up again.
But then we'll make a
shift towards really
focusing on celebrating
our women's product
and showing people that we're
serious about our women's
products.
Retail.
So our retail
environments are really,
in my view, part
of our marketing.
We look at them as
living, breathing things.
They're not museums
for products.
They're really community spaces.
So we activate our stores quite
frequently, two to three times
a month.
We not only throw
our own events,
but we open them up
to the community.
So the local PR association
might hold their annual meeting
in the morning.
We work with Creative Mornings
to hold talks in our stores.
We're currently working with
a local barber shop in Detroit
called The Social Club, too.
They do a series called Shop
Talk, where they actually cut
people's hair while they're
participating in a talk.
It sounds weird, but it works.
If anybody has attended,
they're pretty interesting.
So we're doing that not only
in Detroit and Ann Arbor,
but across cities.
DC, New York, LA.
And each store is really unique,
taking on the personality not
only of the building
that we're in,
but also the city that we're in.
And there's a few.
We're now at is
it 15, 16 stores?
By the end of this year
we'll have 20, and aim
to open eight to 10 every year.
What's next.
The fun part.
Audio.
So come October, November, we'll
start with turntables, working
with this gentleman here,
Alex Rossen, who again,
is a leader within the category.
He started a headphone
brand that he's got on right
there called Audeze.
Looks like he has
waffles on his ears.
But highly regarded within
the audiophile community.
So again, we saw an opportunity.
If you look at what
Beats did, Beats
charges a lot of money for a
product that doesn't really
warrant that price point.
And everyone, you walk
around and you see them.
Sure, a lot of
people in the office
might have Beats headphones.
But our audiophile
friends tell us
that it is not the
quality that it
should be for the price point.
So we saw an opportunity
to bring value
into the category with good
design and audiophile quality.
And then jewelry.
So some of you may
recognize Pamela Love.
She's a designer
out of New York.
We're partnering
with her to launch
jewelry come mid-October.
This will be part of a larger
Shinola women's launch.
So not only jewelry, but
expanding our watch offering
in a new collection
called Gomelsky.
We do have a style right
now called Gomelsky.
But this is sort of
an offshoot of that.
And this is one of
my favorite films
that we did with Bruce Weber.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-You know what?
Um, I think that when
it comes to Detroit,
I view it just how I view love.
Like I feel like in everything
you have like a soul mate.
Right?
If I had to just give like one
line about the city of Detroit,
I would most definitely
say that I belong here.
And it is definitely
a soul mate of mine.
I was working on this
poem a few days ago.
It's about the city of Detroit.
But it's how it breathes
like, greatness, great kids,
great boys, great
girls, how we grow up
to be great men and women.
And I wanted to read it
to you, if that's fine.
"Somewhere in the
projects, there's
a kid working on a project
to project to the world.
He lives in a city that grows
boys and girls into lions
and tigers, a city that
takes the fire and the ashes,
builds, rebuilds,
turns abandoned houses
and empty fields into
things worth looking at.
A place that never looks back.
The center stage of a nation,
the heartbeat, the patience,
the music, the Motown, the
midtown, the downtown, the
always come back around.
We fight for our
reputation, walk, ride,
bike to our destination.
Practice patient knows that
they can't forget about us.
Detroit, the city that continues
to call the world's bluff.
Somewhere there's a kid
working on a project
to project from a city that's
rebuilding, that we building
from the ashes together
so that everywhere there
can be Detroit.
-Beautiful.
God bless you.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
-God bless you.
-I'm glad you liked it.
Thank you.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE].
That was really powerful.
I can see why you like it.
BRIDGET RUSSO: It's
now two years old,
and I think still
totally relevant.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
So you mentioned--
I've heard you
say in some of your
discussions, this idea
of conscious consumerism
and how a brand is
basically responsible for
being a really good brand.
And so when you look
at some of this,
and you can see how
you're investing
in having the best
people, build the products
you want to present.
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
BRIDGET RUSSO: Yeah.
So it's a concept
that I was first
introduced to when
working for Bono and Ali
back in 2004 when they
launched the brand Eden.
And they were really
pioneers in the space,
especially in fashion.
The idea of conscious fashion.
People didn't understand.
The green movement
was happening.
There was some organic
brands out there.
None of them were
all that fashionable.
So this idea that you could
have quality product out there,
but by the nature of
your business practices,
your production
practices, you were also
helping to build communities
and have a positive impact.
Coming from the fashion
industry, where you never
talked about your production,
in part because you didn't want
to let your competitors know
where you were manufacturing,
but also now we
know so many things
have happened since then.
You guys probably
weren't even born yet.
Kathie Lee Gifford.
Nike.
And everything subsequently
that happened from there.
It wasn't pretty.
The fashion industry can
be a pretty ugly industry,
or has been in the past.
Not intentionally.
I think as things went offshore,
that control and understanding
of how things were being
manufactured in other places,
they weren't up to the
same standards as the US.
So a lot of people
early on got burned.
I don't think Nike
set out intentionally
to have children
making their clothes.
But unfortunately, it's hard
to have that control when
you're doing things overseas.
A lot has changed.
But this idea of buying
products and supporting products
that have a positive
impact, whether that's
on the environment, whether
that's on the community,
I think now for millennials
and anyone that's under 30,
I think that's a big part
of that purchase decision.
Certainly as for me,
I'm not under 30.
But I think if all
other things are equal,
I'm willing to pay
a little bit more
to know that this
product is having
some sort of positive impact.
At the end of the day, it still
has to be a strong product.
So we learned it
even the hard way.
We really put the mission
in front of the brand,
and though of product second.
And at Shinola, what I
really loved when I met them,
I was like, wow.
This product is amazing.
The fact that we were
creating jobs to me
was the cherry on top.
But that product needs
to stand on its own.
SPEAKER 1: Do you see that as
being increasingly challenging
as the demand for the
product increases,
and the scale and
the volume that you
need to fulfill that
demand increases?
As we think of other brands
who have maybe mentioned even
Nike in this case.
Do you see that as a
challenge for Shinola?
BRIDGET RUSSO: It's
a huge challenge.
You know, as you grow, and
we really look at everything
we do from in the beginning,
we looked at where
to source our shopping bags.
And we said, well, we can
source them in the States
and spend $12 on them.
Or we could take the savings
of sourcing the bag overseas
and put it towards R&D to doing
what we're doing in Detroit
and helping to grow that.
And since then, we started
with the watch factory.
I didn't mention, but we opened
a leather factory two years ago
where we're producing the
majority of our leather watch
straps and some of our
small leather goods.
So again, continuing to
add to that capacity.
The reality is, we're
in a global economy.
So every single component
is not made under one roof.
That hasn't existed
for a very long time.
We felt very strongly
what we were doing-- we
were doing more than assembly.
And so we use the word "build."
You guys probably read that's
got us into a little hot water
recently.
But I think it's an opportunity
for us to work with the FTC
on clarifying for the consumer
and makers of products to say,
this isn't clear.
It's not clear for the consumer.
And it's not clear
for anyone who's
just trying to do business and
do the right thing in the US.
You know, I can tell you
from experience there's stuff
out there that
says made in Italy
or made in France that is
definitely not made there.
They might add a zipper at
the end, or a small stitch.
And their country
allows them to say
that to preserve their
industry, or what's left of it.
So this is happening
across the board.
You know, the one thing I
can say to anyone, please.
We do do tours.
You're welcome to sign
yourself up for one.
You walk through that factory.
And you see the people there,
most of them Detroiters.
It's hard to say
that we're not having
a positive social impact.
And the most disheartening
thing about it
is when you try and
suggest to these people
that what they're
doing isn't important,
or what they're doing-- I heard
some comments, as people do,
on social media.
Oh, a monkey can do that.
It's like putting
together Ikea furniture.
First of all, I'm
challenged putting together
Ikea furniture.
I'm challenged putting
anything together, it seems.
But it is hard.
A watch is made up of
these tiny little parts.
And to suggest that assembly
is not as complicated
or not an important job.
It takes some level of skill.
You know, that's why we felt
very strongly around the word
"build."
Now we have to
qualify that to make
sure its clear that
its a combination of US
and imported parts,
something that we were always
transparent about when
you look into our FAQs.
In fact, there's a question
is this American made?
And we answer that, and have
done from the very beginning.
But I think that as a
brand, and also the FTC,
need to take this opportunity
to educate the consumer.
Maybe there is a--
like with food.
You know, if you guys
remember with food,
it was sort of the Wild West.
And people-- natural and organic
and what did it all mean.
Well now there are systems in
place and labeling in place.
Maybe we need to do the same
thing with consumer goods.
SPEAKER 1: Well,
it's clear that you
have made an impact in Detroit
beyond today's news of the FTC.
So how does that--
sounds like you've
been trying to do that
regardless of what
retail store-- what location
you open a retail store.
How do you guys factor that
into where you do open them up?
And how do you look to embed
yourselves in the community?
Like I know even
this Saturday you
have a local band playing
at the store in Detroit.
So tell us a little
bit about how
you've continued to look
at where you open stores,
and how important
you've made an impact,
but you're trying to make an
impact in the local market.
BRIDGET RUSSO: I think for
us it's always a balance.
We recently got
some investments.
So we have a board of directors.
And so there's a
responsibility we have now
to a group of people
versus one person.
But we were just actually
having this conversation today.
We're still a baby brand.
So there has to be
that balance of brand
building and making sure that
we're still unique and special
for people, and high touch,
and also getting the ROI
and getting us to
profitability to make sure
that we're being
responsible and also growing
a sustainable brand.
As far as the community
aspect is concerned,
we'll continue to look
at our manufacturing,
not just in Detroit-- we're
actually looking at Chicago
potentially for eyewear.
So parts of the manufacturing
that we can do in the States,
we will.
Whether that's through
our own facilities,
or partnering with facilities
that are out there.
One of our leather
partners potentially
could close, because
their rent's going up.
And they can't afford it.
So it's looking at
that and saying,
maybe we can put them
together with manufacturers
that we know in Florida
to combine efforts.
One is strong in
high end hand-bags.
The other one has great
process and back of house.
How do you bring-- there's
so much time and effort
that we put into these
things to continue
to stand behind our goal, which
is to create American jobs.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
BRIDGET RUSSO: On a local
level, we go into markets
and really either it's
working with an agency
or just going in on our own
and making those relationships
with the local community.
So the local makers,
different organizations
that are working
on job creation,
and really embedding ourself.
In some cases, it might
be as simple as hosting
an event for them in our
store, or a fundraiser,
or donating a watch
for an auction.
But again, making those
relationships on a local
level as well.
And hopefully as we
start to grow and really
start to push through
tentpole initiatives,
I think the idea of
workforce development
is something that we can
be thought leaders in.
So we're talking
now on how do we--
whether it's partnering with Job
Corps, which was started in DC,
but has local chapters
across the US,
and really help playing an
active role in this workforce
development.
Because the reality
is-- and I was just
starting to educate
myself on it--
there's I think it's
something like 2 million
what they call middle
skill jobs out there.
So primarily trade
manufacturing jobs,
that there are no longer that
generation with that skill set.
So it's like a dying
breed of artisans.
And two things need to happen.
One, there needs to
be infrastructure
for the training.
But also a PR
campaign to encourage
people to take these
jobs, because it's
a better job than working
at McDonald's or any
of the big box stores.
And it's an opportunity to learn
a craft and work your way up.
My mother owned a factory.
She started working in
a factory in New York.
And it put food on our table
and put me through school
and through college.
So it is a career opportunity.
And we need to kind
of change the face
of what these jobs are.
They're not dirty jobs.
They're actually career
paths for everyone.
It's not-- some people will
go on and start their own tech
business.
Or some people may decide
they want to be designers.
But there's a lot of
these jobs out there,
and not the skilled
labor force to take them.
And then we have the
unemployment rate.
So you know, these things
can be mutually beneficial.
SPEAKER 1: So was that a premise
at the start, do you think,
for the company at the heart
of it was job creation?
Did it start as really, really
strong, well-made products,
and then the job creation thing?
Because it is a really
interesting component.
You didn't actually
mention I think
eyewear is one of the next areas
that you're going to go into.
So you think about eyewear
and how you would now
repeat this whole process of
finding the right partners
and go about selling it.
So curious about that.
BRIDGET RUSSO: Job
creation was always
part of the conversation,
alongside making
quality products that
were well-designed
and that were classic.
From the business opportunities
standpoint, watches,
for instance.
So you have watches at the
what they call fashion watches.
So Michael Kors and brands
such as that at the $350, $500
range.
And then you have
the high end luxury
watches-- Tag
Heuer and the like.
And no one was really
at our price point
offering the quality with the
great brand story behind it.
So we saw a business
opportunity as well.
Warby Parker's a good example.
They saw a business opportunity.
And they also have
a social impact part
of their business, which if you
notice is not front and center.
It's sort of behind
the scenes, even more
so now than ever before,
when they first launched.
So I think ultimately it has
to start with good product.
It has to be somewhat
of a differentiator
in the marketplace.
And there has to be a positive
impact in some way, shape,
or form, whether it's
double bottom line,
or triple bottom line,
which is hard to achieve.
But you know, I think
it's important now.
And in the long-term,
it's just good business.
SPEAKER 1: So always back to
that conscious consumerism type
thing.
So we're here at Google.
And data is part of our world.
We love data.
And so some of the
marketing examples as a CMO,
you talked about are
traditionally based.
And then a lot of experiential
things you talked about
in your retail stores.
Very experientially based.
So can you talk
to this group who
really looks at a lot of data
in the campaigns and things
that they do, how you
think about marketing
and what kind of
data you look at
based on the things that
are important to you,
and trying to reach
these consumers.
BRIDGET RUSSO: Yeah.
In the beginning we didn't
have data to look at.
We had nothing to
benchmark it against.
Now going into our fourth
year, we do have that data.
And we are diving into that data
and actually working with you
guys, as well as a group
out of DC called Resonate
to really hone in on, OK.
We have this fan base
here of Shinola advocates
and super fans.
We know there are like people
out there who don't even
know we exist yet.
So how do we develop
those personas?
And then we're-- first time
ever, believe it or not,
doing programmatic.
So really looking at like
individuals out there,
and using a lot of
digital to reach them,
really cutting back on print.
I'm a still big fan
on experiential.
I think at the end,
it's about the mix.
It's not like, oh, all
digital is the way to go,
or all print is the way to go.
It's about the
mix, because that's
how people live their lives.
That's how they're consuming
media and information.
So it can't be all one way.
I think part of the
success early on is that--
and again, this is
somewhat anecdotal.
But people would tell me,
oh, you guys are everywhere.
Well, we weren't.
And no way had a budget
to be everywhere.
But we were everywhere where
they were in the right moment.
So you know.
And there was a lot of
great PR value there.
So they saw the PR.
Then they'd go online and
see the social activity.
Then they'd go outside
and see the out-of-home.
It's how that mix
all works together.
And then you have to
be careful-- you know,
the data, depending
on how you look at it,
can drive you in
a direction that
may not be the right direction.
This is somewhat
of a weird example.
But I'll give it to you anyway.
So when I was working for
Bono, he often told this story.
There's an NGO that went
into a village in Kenya.
And the women were
walking like 5 miles
to clean water every day.
And so they came in and they
built a well in the village.
And the women kept
walking the five miles.
Well, no one
stopped to ask them,
we're going to build a well.
Where would you
like us to put it?
So finally, after the fact,
cause they were still puzzled,
they asked, why are you
still walking five miles?
And they said, well, it's
to get away from the men.
That's our time to get away.
No one asked the question.
So they were like, well,
what if we did it halfway?
They're like, perfect.
And that was the
well they went to.
So we can't forget that
this data is great.
But we're all human
beings, right?
And there's aspects
to our behavior
that can't be put
on a spreadsheet.
So the emotion and the
high touch of a brand.
If you can maintain that in
some way, shape, or form,
you know especially when
you have limited dollars,
there has to be that element
of just human nature.
And I don't know the answer for
every brand of what that is.
And I still watch that video,
and think, oh, maybe we
should run that in theaters.
Just because, you
don't even know
what the hell we're selling.
But I'm intrigued.
I want to know more about that
brand after seeing that video.
So it is about the balance.
It's about the mix.
And don't be so
dictated by the data
that you lose the fact that
you are all human beings
and consumers as well.
And that gut feeling of
what is right and taking
some calculated risk.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
I want to open it
up for any questions
that you all might have that
you'd like to ask Bridget.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming in, first off.
I did not know anything
about the association
with the Schwinn family
to your bicycles.
But that seems to be a model
in your brand extension.
A personality or an expert
in the field to kind of
help to launch that.
Can you explain the
process of identifying
that person that represents
best the Shinola brand,
cause I would think it's
more art than science.
Going back to the data, of
like, is it a relationship?
How do you identify that
person that represents how
you want to launch the brand?
BRIDGET RUSSO: We've
been very lucky.
Our founder knows
a lot of people.
And so it's a little bit of
asking around, asking advice
from friends.
And then some people who
just somehow cross our paths
because someone might know
what we're up to and say,
I've got the person for you.
You need to talk to
Sky Yaeger, or you
need to talk to Alex Rossen.
So it's been pretty organic
from that perspective.
And we've never
done big searches.
I mean, even we just
named Tom Lewand, our CEO,
we didn't put the job out there.
We never did.
But we just start to
put our feelers out.
Tom was working with us
on some side projects.
And again, it was
that gut feeling
that our founder felt like
this was the right guy
to help lead the brand.
And so that was
kind of, at least
to date, how decisions are made
around people in particular.
And it makes for a
really-- Tom, our founder,
refers to us as the bar
scene in "Star Wars."
And they took is as that.
We all come from
varied backgrounds.
But I think it's helpful
in keeping us on our toes,
and also seeing
different perspectives.
The fact that Tom comes
from the sports arena,
and coming from that
background, I think
is an interesting perspective
for-- we don't even
like to call ourselves
a fashion brand.
We see ourselves more
as a design brand.
So I think having
those outside voices
and that outside perspective.
Because if you're all in
a room with the same--
if we just had a whole
bunch of fashion people,
we'd be doing things
very differently today.
SPEAKER 1: Question.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: The sklil
trade has always
been kind of a passion of mine.
I grew up downriver
in [INAUDIBLE].
In my parents'
generation had a shop.
They had a actual working auto
shop within the high school
and everything.
And that generation was such
a stigma on [INAUDIBLE].
How do you feel
especially with how deeply
passionate people [INAUDIBLE]
upper middle that probably
came from those families
that had the stigma.
How do you do that?
And where do you start
to try to remove it?
Does it start with politicians?
Does it start in schools?
Does it start with the brand
advocates that you have?
Recalibrating their
brand mindset?
Where'd it really
start to get rid
of that trade school
of underachieving,
and you have to go to
a four-year school.
Because those jobs aren't
gonna [INAUDIBLE] the skills
do transcend and [INAUDIBLE].
BRIDGET RUSSO: Yeah.
I think definitely education
is one piece, and working
at the civil level,
just make sure
that you have the support
locally in these cities,
because there are certain
cities like Detroit that
are more better poised
to really drive this.
Buffalo is another good city.
And also working with
partners in the media who
have such control now to really
shape people's opinions one
way or the other, to
help tell the story.
And you know, especially
now with things like Etsy,
for instance.
I think it's coming
back to where people
are interested in learning how
to make things on their own,
making things and selling them.
Now with the great platform that
you can go direct to consumer.
So it's good timing.
And I think now
with kids coming out
of college with that degree,
that really expensive degree,
and no guarantee of a job, zero.
You know.
So people are looking
at different ways
of how they can build a career.
And it's not the
traditional doctor, lawyer.
Not everyone can
be an entrepreneur
and make the next
Uber or whatever.
So education's a
big piece of it.
But that you need that support
at the civil level to-- oh,
what's the word?
Making sure that there are
certain land agreements,
that it's not just about
building luxury condos.
Because it's very
quick to say a factory
will not yield as much from
a real estate perspective
than a luxury condo.
But you know, that's not going
to help build a community.
And certainly not help build
diversity within the community.
And I'm hoping Detroit
has an opportunity.
And there's a lot of
people working hard at this
to help build this
infrastructure.
And also, if we can
make it work in Detroit,
that's the blueprint, let's
hope, to do it in other cities.
But I was one of those kids
who grew up in the factory.
And I said from
a very young age,
I would never work
in the factory.
My brothers, on the other
hand, did work in the factory.
Made a lot more
money than I did.
Got burned when things
by the '90s, that was it.
But it's all coming back now.
My brother actually
held on to his machines.
And now his knitting
business, he's
getting the phone calls
that-- a lot of people
sold their machines.
He happened to hold on.
But I think there's a
huge opportunity there.
But it's going to be a lot
of different entities working
together.
And there needs to
be a huge PR campaign
that the media can help drive
to change the perception.
SPEAKER 1: So a lot
of people in this room
work with CMOs every day.
They have to go and meet
and provide thoughts, ideas.
Sitting there-- and
obviously you've
had a good PR background.
It's helped set you
up for a lot of things
you're even handling today.
Could you give them advice?
And how do you think
about when people
come in-- you said you
talked to your agency
about the ad that was going to
run when the Apple Watch was
being announced.
Can you give us any advice
for how you think about it?
Or when someone comes in to
talk with you about ideas
or thoughts, how you
think about things?
BRIDGET RUSSO:
For me, I'm always
impressed when someone takes
the time to research your brand.
All the information's
out there now.
Not all of it accurate.
But there is a lot
of sources out there
where you can really educate
yourself about a brand.
I mean, even for people
who are interviewing.
I'm often shocked by people who
don't really do their research.
I went, why are you here?
So do your research.
Help them realize
that you took a moment
to not only understand
their brand,
but to understand
their business.
So not only researching
Shinola, but looking
at where we sit in Nordstrom
and who's our competitive set,
and looking at their business
leading up to a meeting.
You don't need to
become a watch expert.
But just gathering
that information
and bringing that to
the meeting to say,
we looked at your business.
We looked at your
competitive set.
And here's some
learnings that we had
from an outside perspective.
Because often you guys
might see something
that we don't see because
we're in the thick of it.
So I think a fresh approach
to just the information
that's out there before you
even get to the meeting.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
You had a question.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: We all know Detroit is
world-famous for manufacturing.
You talked about that.
But also famous for creativity.
And I wondered if you could
speak a little bit to Detroit's
influence on Shinola designs.
[INAUDIBLE] the
future, especially
with some of these world-class
leaders in the new areas
you're going into being New
York based, as you might expect.
But how is Detroit
perhaps playing the role
of [INAUDIBLE]?
BRIDGET RUSSO:
For us, we're very
from a product perspective,
inspired by the architecture.
So definitely the
architecture of Detroit.
I would say the spirit and
the attitude of Detroit
you see in our marketing.
And sort of the irreverence of
our voice comes from Detroit.
That Detroit versus
everybody sort of sentiment.
You know, I do think that in
order for Detroit to really
be a player as it was in
the global marketplace
from a creativity
innovation standpoint,
it needs to be a place
that maintains its talent,
because often what happens
is the talent's here.
And they leave.
They go to Chicago.
They go to New York, because
the opportunity isn't here.
So as businesses continue
to grow or move to Detroit,
I think that's an
opportunity to get back
in the ranks, if you will,
of being an innovative city,
of being a city that
drives creative.
It certainly inspires
us every day.
But I think being able
to keep the talent that
comes here is something
that we need to work on.
I mean, the education system
is a whole other thing,
because if you're a young person
or if you're coming married
with kids, I don't have kids.
So I live in Detroit.
I'm not worried about the
education system personally.
But it's a huge
problem, because I
have colleagues
of mine that say I
would love to live in Detroit.
But I don't know where to
send my kids to school.
So they'd drive them to
Grosse Point or whatever.
After a while-- first
of all, not everyone
has access to do that.
So those are things that
are really important.
Just basic things.
Our public school system
really needs a lot of work
in order to make this
an attractive city
for creative people, for
business-minded people
to live in, and build
a family, and not
have to go live in the
suburbs because they need
to be in a certain zip
code for their kids
to go to a good school.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Very important.
I'll
One last question
from the audience.
And I'll close with one.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So this may be a
little bit of [INAUDIBLE] here.
When Shinola was
started, to what extent
was Detroit factored in
as the only location?
Or was it like, one of several
locations that were considered?
I've heard how price
point was factored
into choosing Detroit
as a potential location
to headquarter Shinola.
And then part two of that.
As you expand
internationally, what
is the recognition of Detroit
on the international level?
And do you think that
Shinola itself is now
going to become the vehicle
to help promote Detroit?
Rather than Detroit
promoted Shinola,
it almost seems like
it's now Shinola's turn
to promote Detroit [INAUDIBLE].
BRIDGET RUSSO: Well, we
definitely are doing that.
I mean, this brand,
part of our DNA,
what we built this brand on is
the fact that we're in Detroit,
the fact that we
have a watch factory
and a leather
factory in Detroit.
The intention was always that
this would be a global brand.
We didn't know how
the Detroit name would
resonate certainly outside
of Michigan, but even outside
of the US.
What we're finding is people--
it's resonating because it's
that underdog story.
People want Detroit to win.
There's a Detroit everywhere.
So, sorry.
It is resonating.
And I'm choking.
SPEAKER 1: No, don't
choke, don't choke.
It's funny.
Cause I think as we
travel, many of us
travel all over the place.
And we probably all feel that
we're the ones standing up
for Detroit.
I know whether I'm here
or internationally, I
get teased a lot.
Oh, Detroit.
What's happening in Detroit?
And I'm like, come on.
Detroit's great.
So I feel like we're all
feel that a lot of time.
BRIDGET RUSSO: But to
answer the price question.
It wasn't really so much price.
Cause we invested a lot of
money to build the factory
and do the training,
which we continue to do.
And we did not take
the tax incentives
that were offered to us.
Certainly it's cheaper to
open a factory in Detroit
than it is in the middle
of Manhattan or LA.
But really the
opportunity that we saw,
you had a workforce, a
trained and talented workforce
that were sitting without jobs.
So we thought we could transfer
that skill into watchmaking
and leather making.
So sure.
Is it cheaper to open
a factory in Detroit?
Yes.
I mean, that's changing now
with real estate booming the way
that it's doing.
But it wasn't necessarily
about the price.
It was about the opportunity
and the talent base that
exists here in manufacturing.
SPEAKER 1: And so
one last question.
You mentioned Shinola
to be a global brand.
It's only about five years old.
So what are the global
brands, the iconic brands
that may be on the wall or
in the thoughts of those
at Shinola to emulate?
BRIDGET RUSSO: You know, even
though we poked fun at them,
Apple definitely is up there.
And it was all in good fun.
You know, Tesla.
Virgin.
These are all brands
that we aspire to.
I think Tesla would probably
be number one on that list.
You know.
And it's been amazing to
just be a part of what's
happening in Detroit.
We're one of you guys know,
how many people they're
working both small and on a
large scale like Dan Gilbert
to really help bring the
city back on its feet.
And my hope is that
it continues to be
a place of equal opportunity,
that it doesn't just
become my lovely New York,
that million dollar plus condos
that most people can't
afford, because it really
hurts a city when it becomes
homogeneous like that.
So you have to make sure there's
a balance of opportunity that
maintains the diversity.
That's one thing that I think
New York lost over the years,
because now you turn around,
and everywhere you go-- I mean,
Bed-Stuy, which I
remember growing up
as a kid in Brooklyn,
you just didn't go there.
And now it's like luxury
apartment buildings
and townhouses all
over the place.
So.
And that's going to keep
the creativity here as well.
SPEAKER 1: Well, we want
to thank you for your time.
We know how busy you are.
And we have a
little gift for you.
And thank you for being
part of our first talks
at Google in the
Birmingham office.
BRIDGET RUSSO: Thank
you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]